donnez moi du courage des journalistes
du courage il en fallait ce matin
isabelle fouilloux avant d'aborder cette
journée décisive lors de la
confrontation tant attendue avec
johnattan celle de nouveaux aveux
peut-être difficile d'en être convaincu
pour jean-pierre fouilloux juste avant
son témoignage c'est nathalie les
plonger leurs conventions et
je pense qu'il n'en sortira pas j'espère
de tout coeur que il y a phénomène un
déclencheur qui puisse opérer le
contraire mais j'ai de gros doutes
à la barre le père d'alexia et ému mais
reste dit il parle de sa fille
longuement la dcri telle qu'elle était
alexia c'était notre lumière lance-t-il
après sa disparition c'est nous qui
avons pris perpétuité
le moment à la fois chargée d'émotion
chargez pas de colère mais de deux rangs
de rancoeur à chaque fois que j'avais
des mots durs entre parenthèses mais qui
ne sont pas des mots durs qui sont les
mots de la réalité johnatan baisser les
yeux l'émotion est encore plus grande
quand en début d'après midi isabelle
fouilloux s'avance à son tour à la barre
en larmes elle dit être là pour sa fille
et vouloir obtenir des réponses avant de
s'adresser directement à johnattan si tu
veux sortir grandi de cette histoire si
tu veux pouvoir te regarder dans une
glace johnatan je veux te donner cette
chance de dire enfin la vérité lauriers
mais qui vous regarde regarde mais déjà
moi de le regarder c'était déjà quelque
chose parce que nous on est assis on ne
le voit pas très bien donc vous là je le
voyais et c'est vrai qu'ils pleuraient
il pleurait quand je lui ai lu la lettre
la journée s'est conclue avec les
auditions de stéphanie et grégory gay la
soeur et le beau frère d'alexia près de
six heures d'audition des parties
civiles qui ont visiblement éprouvés
johnattan d'aval